hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play gray okay
so shits about to go down yeah so one of
the tips on the loading screen coming in
here was pay attention to the small
details there's a lot of innocuous items
just lying around so I got to be very
mindful it seems that way I suspected it
was gonna be like that still don't have
a flashlight ah the light on that Sarah
camera phone oh I hope this flashlight
has batteries as a flashlight
how about kaboom yeah oh yeah now I
haven't been able to check the comments
yet because I record a few episodes in a
row so if you guys know if this is the
same voice actor as in cry hear that
voice is Simon please let me know I'm
very curious about that sort of thing oh
oh no I'm going to love this oh don't
say that guy hello chairs hi I can't
pick you up this time the lock is jammed
oh here we go ah these batteries every
one is just [ __ ] gone I should go to
the car repair shop my boss should be
there wha
there are a couple buttons that I'm
trying out that Sh closes mm oh whatever
figure it out I don't know I don't see
like a meter for the flashlight so on
for now I'm just gonna be using it but
obviously I got batteries so I can run
out so I'll try to be conservative okay
all right
amnesia has taught me a lot in terms of
not wasting your light source
ah-hoo Joe Byrne introduced I want to
break through there
can i let's be flipping through the
inventory slots nothing here oh yeah
nope fail why don't you just punch me in
the face why don't you push down there
ah what's this last year when I got out
of the halfway house
the streets were much cleaner else
now yeah so this guy was once in a
halfway house that says something
it's locked from the outside okay most
of these are locked I guess it would
behoove me to try them all at least I'm
actually curious if the the team who
made cry fear and afraid of monsters
team sigh Keller if their next game is
gonna be on the half-life 1 engine or ah
what's this well open it Dom you maybe I
don't need it and that's why it's never
okay if the next game is going to be on
half-life 1 or half-life 2 I'd like I'd
like it to be on housing too not that
there was anything wrong with cry for
graphics was invaded an insane amount of
of improvements to the engine
big punk huh
house just go
and seem to be anything around I'm
really trying to look and hunt down
everything but even these inconspicuous
rooms seem to have nothing in them so I
mean I'm trying
what's that surcharge on oh okay
oh it's brightly lit I wonder how long
that's gonna last hey Doc he's jammed
the first-aid he's jammed the door is
jammed to beam back he's jammed the
chair sir
what's wrong with you cheers oh they're
too cheesy Slav from the other side I
don't like this I don't like this I
don't like this
is this your boss's chef oh hello
what done it's on your arm buddy
through block 12 what what down through
block 12 yeah
[ __ ] up enough to leave bloody notes
over the place alone I've seen one but
maybe I missed others no I've been
pretty thorough about it okay that's
that's closing opening okay I got and
tab is just a little note there anyway
I'm at the shop I got a key but I don't
know what to do with it
things are about to get ridiculous right
they can I like bash my way through this
hurt oh yeah I can cool
now is there anything about Kier worth
kidding I don't know I did that I just
kind of rammed my shoulder into it he's
my big G I can't toy muscles
yeah I'm tough but there's nothing in
here but nothing in here yeah huh that's
weird
oh well maybe something later is gonna
happen no no I have a feeling it's gonna
make me come back here so because that
first-aid kit is there there's nothing
in here nothing at all
all right say V yeah ah oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
yeah no no no no no no no not gonna
happen it's locked
just like everything here so at least
people are smart enough to lock up after
themselves safety first
okay so I got the key now what do I do
with the key I have to go somewhere but
I don't know where what do I do with
this key oh there we go that's what the
key is for Sadie hello is anybody home
oh don't tell me I'm going into
apartments from hell
Oh guys any of you guys see my cry fear
let's play you guys know about the
apartments from hell ah I knew it
mom mom how could you tell that was your
mama
and why aren't you more freaked out
about that couldn't you be like wait a
minute I think I'm going crazy I just
saw something pop out of a wall and the
lights flickered I might be insane the
log is jammed this log is not jammed
what's going on here yeah there's just a
bunch of rooms with nothing in them oh
I'm really I'm smashing my e button as I
ah Bing bong
I found one of her neatest dolls that
makes two I've gotten now I don't know
there's no score counter that I can see
so I won't know if like the end of the
game it'll like telling him of farting
I'm really trying to be very thorough
got him in the partners from hell oh ah
that guy is dead something tells me I'm
about to get a weapon or a key Keys cool
- I see it thank you for pointing it out
to me got it this Keys labeled for the
back exit
I've got to hurry I'll take my time
thank you
I can't even get over there yeah I'm not
gonna run in anything that I'm not ready
for oh it show the apartments from hell
hello paintings hi there and I hope that
piece by Ian wheeze got your emotions
all stirred up I know I that yeah
tune in you are listening to Fenster
local radio Ragnar host DJ aqua shoes
high off the shoes of the classical hour
if that's the local radio and next up is
Stig Sood tongue and with his rendition
of yeah badder than hot smelly by
Kristen sending dye bath and then Hobson
in fear or something like that
right bad and hub Senate beaters
whatever it was I don't speak Swedish I
just have a for some strange reason I
have a sweet attraction nothing I
suppose
flickering legs oh that's going back
with Herman well there's nothing down
here all the back exit would be over
here that's right our doors just
randomly slamming wait where is it
where's the back exit in here no no way
it's just in there there's nothing now
no right I'm not going crazy or anything
there's nothing here
some behind the paintings baby maybe in
this maybe in this apartment there was
something paintings I could actually use
them either way I don't like any of this
it's just nothing's happening which is
like the worst in a horror game when
nothing happens that's when you should
worry okay all right I guess there's
nothing then haha I'll be on my way home
then keep slamming I think it's just the
doors but whatever okay okay okay okay
anything under the stairs nothing it's
never anything under the stairs for me
back exit yeah or no I've made my way
through the majority at block 12 I
continued on determined to find someone
or something up ahead was a construction
site abandoned some time ago
the decrepit shells of half built
buildings stood around me the hairs on
the back of my neck began to rise I felt
like I was being watched huh it's been
too long with nothing happening
that's the worst the absolute worst oh
it's so bad cuz I know something's gonna
happen any second now
something something how is that even
powered this is illogical
oh hello it's a doll up here
oh no no thank you
oh do I have to get up there somehow
alright I gotta get through these boards
somehow oh hello
yeah feel the board's rub your face
against a man ah weapon yes finally
something to defend myself god
oh hello what could I do that I can
never do that before
give me that yes Oh get ready for a
whacking hey punk
Oh best oh shut up TweetDeck who wants
to get bum
yeah ah cement mixer do you do not cross
oh don't tell me what to do
haha Oh make something happen or don't I
don't know I've got a pipe it's so dark
why is it dark ah
I can finally bash some boxes now with
my Furley biceps yeah - lay down please
think about pink Bank Bank bank okay no
stance BAM pull this back bone pink pink
Bert King canoe I really don't think I
should
yeah you're just starting to get that
feeling that felt that feel I'm coming
okay actually I'm happy because I am out
of time and there's a freaking me out
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye